well I think the first thing to say in
terms of tips for educators is to really
encourage you or really encourage them
to to do it it's a very rewarding
experience I think that the opportunity
to engage with community organizations
and assistive technology users people
with disabilities in the wider community
beyond a college campus is you know for
us as instructors a very rewarding and
exciting experience and you also find
within the university itself a lot of
support and interest people who want to
bring their own experiences or different
aspects of the university that you know
maybe work in assistive technology or
student disability services that really
get very excited or in design or in
engineering and so on and the students
themselves I think it's it's really a a
special group of students who's who are
interested in this topic I think that's
really one of the that's really probably
the biggest kind of joy of working in a
class like this the kind of experiences
that students bring to the table the
dedication that they bring to the to the
class so there's sort of a big need out
there there's sort of a big interest
from students the other core part I
would say is there's no doubt I mean
logistically it's always a lot of work
to bring together different partners or
find people out in the community and
find lab spaces and places to build
prototypes and so on and I wouldn't even
claim that we tried to make it
particularly efficient this year I think
to us
particularly given the circumstances and
given that you know we were doing this
for the for the first time we tried a
lot of experiments we that that you know
did require more time to set up that
might be something one thing to say to
that might be there might be more sort
of efficient ways to put this all
together but the big thing that I think
comes to mind is that it's really the
the students working with their clients
or it's really the results of this
interaction between the students and
their client that really motivates
students to to learn and to develop new
skills and to put a lot of time and
effort into their projects I really
think that the way the the relationship
between clients and students is set up
or really drives the course it's really
the clients that work with the students
who do a really substantial part of the
teaching associated with the class so in
terms of kind of learning outcomes or in
terms of the things that students learn
in the class is really big gains I guess
to be gotten from a setup
like this I have two tips for ever
educated I think the first one is before
the semester starts do all your homework
as to where all the resources within
your school are and in within your
community because you have no idea where
the projects are going to go and what
helping your students are going to need
there is no way that you yourself are
going to possibly have all the skills to
teach them how to do things so just make
as many friends as possible who are on
your side and who are willing to help
out the students with their projects the
second tip is that
eighty percent seventy to eighty percent
of the work is all about people
management uh-huh
at the end of the day you're trying to
facilitate students working for a client
and the students as you usually novices
at this and most of the trouble that the
students have come down to the client
Wednesdays or the client is doing this
and it's really discouraging or we don't
know how to do this for them and so
being able to facilitate that
relationship becomes a big part of the
work one other tip I would share is
really in terms of the the set up of the
class I think we really do believe that
working with a real clients over the
semester is really at the core of of
this as opposed to maybe working more
theoretically in terms of assistive
technology design or kind of a
generalized more abstract need I think
what I've seen is it really sharpens the
particular need that students identify
and try to fulfill it certainly
motivates students to try to get their
project working and it also just ends up
I think being you know just a stronger
learning experience for everybody
everybody involved just the kind of that
human side of things so there's a lot of
I know there's a lot of moving parts in
the class that we've put together this
semester but from what I've seen I think
working with a client and and I think
that associated with that is the the
efforts to identify the right groups of
people to work with
I think is
really important and I think there's
some question you know always a bad well
if you work with one particular person
does that mean you sort of overfit to
that particular person is this kind of
product only going to be useful to that
one person in the world perhaps and the
answer might be yes
sometimes I mean it's very customized
and it works hopefully for that
particular person and intrinsically I'd
argue at least that that's that's a good
thing but the other aspect and I think a
student wrote about this and one of the
blog posts is that I think doing this
kind of design for one and making it
work and and really can be a successful
way of teaching design or teaching
engineering and could lead as well to
kind of successful ideas or successful
solutions in assistive technology that
are applicable to more than one person